so is is Howard Stern like as big as he
was like are you guys trying to get on
Howard Stern anymore to promote I mean I
would love to I mean I'm a huge fan as a
kid he's got a little queefy over the
years you know he's not what he used to
be he used to be fun as hookers he's
throwing cold cuts at a woman's ass and
there's a weird black crackhead great
great stuff yeah Beetlejuice yeah and
now it's kind of like oh hey I shouldn't
have said this and you're like get out
of here you cashed all those checks when
you were in blackface you son of a [__]
and uh now you're like oh I've evolved
oh come on you Jerry curled [__] get out
of here
why do you think that is because he
switched to AGT and got family friendly
that's what it is yeah and and I think
the climate changed
I don't remember the climate but uh but
distinctly and this this is close to my
heart and it really hurts me because I
count
16 different times that I went on the
Howard Stern wow yeah 16 16 man I was
like a go-to man every time I went in
there I would do something that just
like made Howard uncomfortable and that
would make just great radio I'd be
stapling my balls to my leg like I'd be
like I mean I went in there and and uh I
swallowed five goldfish wow
I would take it to another level I
brought like naked chicks with me like
it was just like constant craziness I
like I remember I would I had to deal
with them
that I would tell him something I
shouldn't tell him about another
celebrity yep for every plug
I'm gonna earn myself a plug by telling
you like who I just did there
Knoxville's impotent there we go check
out my new book or whatever
and um man it was it was just a lot of
fun dude in a plug from Howard Stern's
pretty [__] awesome
it was rad Game Changer and um
and and you know what too is that I
didn't even regularly listen to the
Howard Stern Show for all that time when
I was regularly on it I was just like a
crazy drug addict and and whatever you
know so like and I was on it all the
time then like uh around the time he got
on uh AGT yeah he became a judge on
America's Got Talent which no one saw
coming right nobody saw it coming and he
was great on it you know sure he was
great on it and then like then he became
like uh
family friendly yeah that's like and and
it was about that time
when I got this serious exam
subscription and I regularly listened to
the Howard Stern Show like not only do
they regularly listen to it but I would
only listen to it on the app on my phone
so that when I got out of the car it
would pause the you know I remember that
very careful to not like uh
like I became like a die hard he's great
he's the best interviewer hands down and
at that time as soon as I started
listening to it that I couldn't get on
the show anymore
like it's so crazy I mean like they'd
let me on the wrap-up show and I'd get
on there and talk I think it's you
thought it was because you opened up the
elevator at Sirius I don't know about
that I don't think that that's got it I
think just because Howard became the
image changed family friendly kind of in
like he his standard for the caliber of
guests that he would have on like just
went crazy through the roof Plus he
started only doing three days a week
like so there was less opportunities to
get in there right and I just like like
he only wants like super A-list like
major Mega celebrities and uh so I can't
get on the show anymore but the irony
was better when it was when you were
doing it the show it was a better show
and that's the other thing is that back
in the day he he would ask every guest
like what celebrities have you slept
yeah how much money do you make like it
was all sex and money like really like
crazy so big time celebrities were
afraid to go on the Howard Center
because they didn't want to be asked
those questions and he could pull it out
of anybody he was the best at that but
now he doesn't do that anymore because
he does he wants to have like the
craziest A-list celebrities so like
everybody knows they can go on there and
not right in an uncomfortable situation
he won't put anybody in an uncomfortable
situation so do you think that's why his
ratings went down I don't know what it
was sure probably right yeah I would say
so I mean I grew up watching him and you
watched it for the crazy [__] like the
Artie Lang years he's nodding off on
heroin yeah you know they have girls
getting on the sybian yeah that was hot
I used to rub one out to that show
remember that I remember he offered John
Bobbitt like an obscene amount of money
to see his dick whoa when he did that
big party it was like uh I don't know
60s no no it was like way he was like in
the 90s I remember I was watching it
like when the whole John Bobbitt thing
was going on and just kept giving ten
thousand dollars ten thousand dollars
it's crazy when Mark was just sitting
here kind of like
bashing Howard like I got like really
uncomfortable I'm sorry no no no I don't
like because you're not gonna be able to
go on I'm just like you can't go on
anyways like what do I even care about
like I have this reverence for Howard I
do too
and it just hurts me that he changed
because I you know he got a seat at the
table being that guy and then you get to
the table finally and you change it's a
bummer it's like marrying a woman you
love and then she transitions
you know yeah what do you do in that
situation yeah what are we doing here I
like your vagina now it's all [__] up
and twisted and mangled
for sure I'll still do it thank you yeah
I'll still do it you know I'd [__]
Elliott page but you know
that's very genius
um the uh
threw me right you have a memorable
Howard Stern experience out of all the
16 times
when my last book came out my my uh my
newest book a hard kick in the nuts it
just came out I made a special video for
Howard to try to get on Howard Stern to
promote this book
and and this is when we were at a venue
there was a Huntington a theater that
was so big that our tour bus was like
parked underneath like in a special like
you know
but there wasn't outside the arena when
it was in an arena but it wasn't outside
it was in it was underneath and I'm like
in the bowels of this huge impressive
thing and I said Hey Howard like uh
yeah
um here I am in this this venue's so big
my bus is is like underneath it and I
show them like the tour bus all wrapped
Stevo and I'm like I'm like real proud
of it I bought my own tour bus hell yeah
like I got this book coming out I said I
know you love it when people talk about
the celebrities they've had sex with in
my new book like literally like just
lists that it just goes right into every
one of them Howard and like I know you
like people talking about money and I
was like Howard I'm killing it a minute
I'm gonna tell you everything I'm like
how I'm killing and I miss you dude like
I used to be on the show all the time
like 16 times I was on now I haven't
been on in like a decade man and it's
like I want my relationship with you
back yeah
throw some more stuff
I mean I'd love to do the show too but
it just sucks it's a bummer but you know
look how cute you were look how young
what were you you don't get to do for
being handsome you were a handsome guy
back in the day oh I don't know I mean
now you look like uh the Crypt Keeper
but back then you were a cute kid you
have a favorite whack Packer oh man I
liked uh Bob that it was a tatard
yeah I've seen already Lang pop up on
different podcasts is he still sober do
you see him around New York ever in the
club he's uh he's a whole different guy
he looks different but his nose is
better yeah it's getting there and his
hair is white now and he's lost a ton of
weight and he's hanging in there and
he's still goddamn hilarious he's always
going to be hilarious man I love Hardy
oh he's the first time I was ever on the
Howard Stern Show the very first
appearance I walked in there and uh I
was like where I said uh like I'm gonna
swallow five goldfish that was my first
time on yeah and uh and and I think
Howard said no you don't have to do that
and I said Howard I didn't come here to
waste your time yeah and already said
God bless you I said he says I love this
guy he says you know how many people
come in here specifically to waste our
time
was just like I had this uh you know
this this wonderful relationship with
Hardy that started that started like at
that moment yeah he was always super
supportive of me and uh and and back and
forth you know I'd love to hear him
doing well yeah what do you think of
these because a lot of people have you
know the climate has changed as we said
and a lot of people have gone a certain
way you know you got to fit the The
Narrative or whatever it is you got to
go with the way the wind's blowing and
evidently you don't because you well I'm
nobody I still have some freedom in this
business you know I'm not in a Marvel
movie but my point is did they sit up in
bed at night and go man that was fun and
uh it's kind of hard pretending to not
stink think that stuff is still funny or
do you think they actually believed
their own [__] they might get into like
a relationship or something and like
what types of people are we talking
about here like big celebrities who used
to be kind of on the edgier side yeah
and then they they clean up the rack
which like if anybody has a company
Jesus moment and look I get if you want
to keep their jobs
example of one of these well I mean he's
a perfect example but other than that uh
uh well there's some comedians I don't
want to name who have got huge off of
being irreverent and whatever and now
they're like Amy Schumer accounts in
that category ah we'll see I think
actually she's still pretty gnarly
pretty gnarly yeah yeah actors yeah I'm
trying to think of now I'm drawing a
blank because I'm so hungover but I know
what you're saying I think it's just
kind of the climate and you're like well
it's especially when they they go out
and speak politically and you're like
this [__] guy believes that right
right right I can't I can't think of
anybody but I know who you're talking
you know what I'm talking about yeah and
I just wonder if they're at home in the
shower going like all right I gotta buy
another day you know uh I got through it
or if they're like no no I believe all
the [__] I think they probably get in a
relationship and they like you know say
some of the jokes to their chick or
they're do and they're like the [__] did
you just saying it's right well [__] or
who I used to be Isaac are over here
actors that were gnarly in our now song
that's
hilariously yeah yeah but do you think
that
climate is gonna change back like like
do you think it's gonna be like a
pendulum where I hope so yeah but you're
not going to forget who flipped it's
just weird look if you want to evolve
and you want to be who you are I get it
and that's all good but you just happen
to be doing it the exact way that it's
fashionable that's the part that bothers
me like oh that really lined up
perfectly for you how convenient do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your butt
hole are available on Amazon and if you
want a real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude